الناس تكون في السقعه وفي الشتاء الناس
اللي بتقعد جنب القانون كل شعب غزه ايه
بتدفوا
ففيه اطبال على الحقيقه
[موسيقى]
في اقبال عنا على الحطب كويس بس كل ما
سقعت طبعا انت عارف اليوم الغاز غالي
والكهرباء بتطلع ثمان ساعات وبعده جوه
اكثر
[موسيقى]
فاكهه الشتاء الفاكهه بتاعه الشيطان طبعا
احنا طول عمرنا يعني تعودنا على النار مش
طول عمرنا بنستعمل على النار يعني احنا
حتى الان انا عندي في بيتي يعني احطه على
السطحلت حاططناعي
[موسيقى]
يعني فش عندنا داخل
وايش بدنا نعمل بدنا نعيش يعني كيف بدنا
نطعم اولادنا كيف بدنا نطبخ كيف بدنا ناكل
الا على النار
[موسيقى]
تعالي المره التدفئه هو البديل الذي وضعته
الناس كبديل لارتفاع اسعار الغاز
والمحروقات وانقطاع التيار الكهربائي لكن
هذا الامر ادى الى حدوث مشاكل اخرى منها
تلوث البيئه ومنها التاثير سلبي في مساله
الانحباس الحراري فهو يساهم في
تفاقم ظاهره الاحتباس الحراري وزيادتها
انا في المكان
ولا غرفه نوم